is a staff research scientist at
deepmind
he's firmly established himself as one
of the most significant and
up-and-coming researchers in the Deep
learning space
he invented graph attention networks in
2017 and he's been a Leading Light in
the field ever since pioneering research
in graph neural networks geometric deep
learning and also neural algorithmic
reasoning recently he's been applying
category Theory to take the geometric
deep learning ideas one step further if
you haven't already you should check out
our show that we did on the geometric
deep learning blueprint which of course
featured better and I caught up with him
last week at nurips enjoy
better it's fantastic to see you again
so this is the first time that I've
actually met you in person we did that
really cool show together on geometric
deep learning with your Proto book with
Taco I smoked taco yesterday but also uh
Michael bronstein and and Joanne Bruna
so anyway it's been a little while since
we've um since we've really synced
um now you've had this really really
interesting um category Theory series
can you start by um you know just
letting us know what you've been doing
that yeah that's a great uh great point
and great to finally meet you in person
Tim it's uh it's uh it's really great uh
to to catch up after after some time has
passed and uh yeah I mean I like to
think that uh all four of us myself
Michael Jean and Taco uh have a greater
understanding of the implications of
these methods since the last time we
spoke if you remember back when we did
our conversation I kind of hinted at the
fact that category Theory might hold
some of the answers to maybe generalize
some of these uh geometric Concepts
beyond the notion of just pure
symmetries and we believe that now we
have a sufficient understanding of these
kinds of things that we were able to
make this kind of mini course on
categories for deep learning and to me
it really feels like the natural
continuation of these concepts of
geometric deep learning into the realm
Beyond and I'll explain that I'll
explain that in a moment but one other
kind of very related point is that here
at neurops we're actually presenting a
full conference paper which deals with
using category theoretic tools to invent
new kinds of graph neural networks so
basically it's uh it's not just that
we're throwing a bunch of new Theory it
actually leads to empirical findings
that we can actionably use in our models
day-to-day so that's one point that is
incredible can can you sketch out the
paper yeah sure so basically maybe I'll
first take a step back to explain uh why
do we think categories are important and
in what sense they're kind of a step
further from what geometric deep
learning already gives us yeah so
geometric deep learning concerns itself
with giving us these equivariant layers
right so layers that are in some sense
resistance to a operations of these
symmetry Transformations that
fundamentally change an object but the
object is still the same we still have
all of it right and this immediately
implies that these symmetries have to be
composable invertible all that sort of
stuff and yeah essentially the the
category Theory framework is in some
sense mindful of the fact that while
symmetries are a very nice way to reason
about things that happen and that we see
in nature they're often not completely
an accurate representation of what
happens very often there are operations
both in nature but especially in general
computation like say in algorithmic
stuff where an operation of an algorithm
might destroy half of your data so that
is no longer a symmetry you cannot
invert it but you might still be
interested in building a neural network
model that is in some sense resistant to
the operations of of say this algorithm
or this natural phenomenon that you that
you're studying one simple example that
maybe predates our work a little bit is
building some kind of equivariants
scaling operations obviously if you
scale or course in something these are
not always invertible Transformations
because if you coarsen the pixels of
your image you cannot perfectly
reconstruct where you came from yet you
still might want to build a model that
will give you the same answer as
regardless of how you scale up your
input right so these are obviously
things that are going to be very
important as we move to more generic
domains than ones that can be described
purely through geometric and symmetry
Transformations right and in that sense
the same way we had groups
representations and equivariants in
geometric deep learning these are all
special cases of categorical Concepts
like categories functors and natural
Transformations which basically
generalize all the stuff of geometric
deep learning into their own Beyond and
in our paper we try to use exactly these
kinds of category theoretic tools to
study what it would mean to build a say
graph neural network that is capable of
behaving like a classical computer
science algorithm in the sense that if
you have some data that's transformed by
an algorithm you may imagine say a
pathfinding algorithm where at every
step in every node you have your
knowledge of how far away is that node
from The Source vertex and one step of
the algorithm kind of looks at all the
immediate neighbors and updates those
beliefs of how far away you are and I'll
say you want to have a gnm that
simulates that like we typically do in
algorithmic reasoning you take your you
know algorithmic State you encode it
with a neural network into this High
dimensional space your GNN then
processes it to update the latent space
and now you want to be able to decode it
right so that you predict whatever the
next state is going to be so you have
something which in category Theory we
use a lot is known as a commutative
diagram so basically it's saying you can
either take the step of the algorithm or
you can encode process decode and
hopefully end up in the same place so
category Theory seems like a very nice
language to study these kinds of uh I
won't call them symmetries they're
basically like you know interchangeable
sequences of operations because the step
of an algorithm might not be invertible
you might not be able to go back after
you do one step of you know shortest
path algorithm because it's a
contraction map right when you find the
final solution of a shortest path
algorithm you won't necessarily know
which previous state LED you there
because there could be many equivalent
states that could lead you to the same
contracted solution right so our method
using these category Theory Frameworks
try to characterize how these graph
neural networks align with a Target
algorithm that we might want to simulate
and we detect various ways not only to
explain the code of graph neural
networks from this kind of perspective
but also it gives us a very interesting
sort of if you've done any functional
programming a type Checker of sorts to
kind of detect whenever we're using our
representations in slightly broken ways
so specifically to give you one very
concrete example
in a categorical framework just like in
functional programming you expect your
transformations to be functions that is
for every input there should be a unique
output however one thing that people
very often do in graph representation
learning when they want to predict
outputs not only in the nodes but also
in the edges is to reuse the edge
messages both as Edge outputs and
integrated over all the other messages
to get node outputs right but this is
the problem from the categorical
perspective because this is no longer a
function you cannot get a function that
takes you know edges to edges plus nodes
without sending the same thing into two
different places in this case right and
you know just because it mathematically
breaks doesn't mean you cannot implement
it in fact 99 percent of the GNN
implementations you'll find online will
do this exactly in this particular way
deepmind's graph Nets Library does this
for example however you know just
because you can implement it doesn't
mean that there's something not
potentially a bit tricky going on in the
sense that you're putting a bit of
representational pressure on that edge
message right because now now it has to
be used for two potentially very
different things both for some output in
the edges but also it needs to be
integratable into nodes where it
predicts something potentially wildly
different and you know while gradient
descent can take care of this and give
you a model that fits your training
distribution well you're not like to
deal with this pressure it's probably
going to have to learn something which
has nothing to do with the algorithm
that you want to align to and as a
result you're out of distribution
extrapolation performance is going to be
much much worse and any self-respecting
algorithm should extrapolate well that's
the main property of algorithmic
reasoning right and we find that just by
you know splitting this message function
into two streams one which goes into the
edges and one which goes into the nodes
we get basically significant empirical
benefits When extrapolating on edge
Centric algorithms yeah amazing so um
Peta has just produced this incredible
series which is available on YouTube
where can folks find it yeah so
basically if you just go to
cats.4.ai you can see all of the main
series lectures from our course which
the starts off with assuming kind of a
foundational knowledge of deep learning
with neural networks back propagation
and so on and then also tries to
introduce these concepts of category
Theory and how we can use them to
rethink the way we might go about some
of our standard ideas in deep learning
like compositionality or functional
structure of deep learning pipelines or
even how can we reinterpret back
propagation from the perspective of
categorical Theory and each lecture
basically deals with one particular
aspect and it we try to keep it grounded
from the beginning to keep it motivated
so every single lecture is aligning
itself with one particular top tier
paper that one of us has published on
one of these venues like in Europe's and
one thing I'll also mention is that the
course is actually in principle still
ongoing because besides the main series
of five lectures that myself Bruno Pym
and Andrew have given we also have
several interesting guest lectures where
we try to bring in other influential
people at the internet section of
popularizing category Theory with deep
learning Concepts
in a way that can like bring an even
wider area of views once you're kind of
trained in the basics of these
techniques how they are applied to
various other things like causality we
had Taco Co and tell us about how he
uses these Concepts to reimagine
causality through a categorical lens we
have we're going to have Titan a Bradley
she's a very popular mathematics
educator generally she will show how she
introduced some of these Concepts to
explain Transformers and one thing I'm
very excited about early next year we
will have actually a guest talk from
David Spivak which is one of the
co-authors of the very famous seven
sketches and compositionality book which
is what initially one of the things that
got me really excited about category
theory in the first place so I'm really
Keen to to hear all these perspectives
as well yeah the man is a legend and
also on Taco I interviewed him yesterday
and his work on causality is really
really exciting
um what would you say to people who
might be intimidated or scared by
category theory that is so one thing
that uh that I should mention here is
that one point about being Intimidators
care about category theory is that to
like really be able to utilize these
ideas in how you do research or build
your models or anything it does require
a reasonably significant buy-in so this
is not something that you can just read
one blog post and suddenly you're
empowered to do it this is like one key
thing but I would say the main thing
that might make people a bit scared to
do it is the fact that many category
Theory resources out there are a bit
guided towards mathematicians so they
will tend to use the kind of language
and the kind of examples that will be
quite attractive to someone who has
studied say various kinds of
differential geometry or topology or
something like this and these kinds of
areas tend to generally scare off people
who come from a more computer science
style background and basically I would
say the answer to that is you need to
find the right resource for you category
theory is no more or no less than a way
to take a bird's eye view of the
phenomena that you try to study and when
you study these phenomena from behind
the sky details become invisible but you
suddenly get a much better feel for the
structure and you can utilize kind of
the nice patterns that reappear across
various fields and this you would argue
is kind of the essence of what we're
trying to do in deep learning we have a
lot of analogical way in which these
architectures are constructed right so
cats for AI is one possible answer to
that it's our way to kind of as half of
us are deep Learners and half of us are
category theorists trying to apply these
techniques to deep learning we believe
we have a sort of unique perspective if
we and like we understand what makes
people afraid to try to talk about these
things because some of us had to go
through it ourselves to deal with the
the way in which the materials are
arranged online right now so yeah maybe
just these kinds of resources starting
with them and basically trying as much
as possible not to descend into the
depths of ncat lab as the very first
thing that you do can be a good way to
maybe stay sane during the first few uh
you know weeks or months of trying to
explore this field wonderful I wondered
if you could give a couple of examples
of where category um theory has been
used in an adjacent field I can think of
too I can think of Rosen using category
Theory to describe um you know sort of
ecosystems and life I can also think of
some quantum mechanics folks that have
come up with a category category
theoretical conception of of quantum
mechanics are there any other ones yeah
so I mean I can start by giving the
examples that I know about closest in
terms of just deep learning so one
particular example that I think could be
quite interesting is the work that was
published at neurops two years ago which
I think is one of the first papers that
really tried to use categorical Concepts
to build these structures is the natural
graph networks paper from Pim de Han
type of coin and Max swelling which
effectively
realizes the fact that the way we build
grapheneurial networks very often we
have this one shared message function
that's applied everywhere on every
single edge on every single graph that
you get but in reality is this necessary
for it to be a legitimate graph neural
network that's actually not the case
because if I give you two completely
non-isomorphic graphs if I choose to
have completely different message
functions in those two graphs that's
totally fine because it's still a valid
graph net if I permute any of those
graphs I'll get the permutation
equivalent function for the two of them
separately there needs to be no weight
sharing between them and naturally
Concepts like these so this kind of
requires taking a step above the group
theoretic view of of geometric deep
learning and into the realm of what is
known as a groupoid you kind of imagine
every single graph structure isomorphic
graph structure living on a sort of
island of possible adjacency Matrix
representations of it and for those
graphs living on those islands you need
to have some weight sharing but for
separate Islands you don't need to have
any weight sharing whatsoever of course
in practice these kinds of layers you
would need to have some kind of sharing
of Weights in order to make them
scalable to arbitrary new graph
structures you haven't seen at training
time but it allows you a lot more
flexibility about how you go about
building your functions and you're no
longer constrained to have just one
function everywhere repeated right so
that's maybe one example that at least
to me was what first motivated me and
made me realize that there's more to
this stuff than just say what group
Theory will give us yeah amazing and I'm
really interested in your work in
algorithmic reasoning I know you were
just discussing it as as an adjacent
thing and I mean I very soon we want to
make a show actually on on your work on
that but if you wouldn't mind could you
just sketch out algorithmic reasoning
yes wonderful so uh very happy to
basically
um what are we interested in algorithmic
reasoning is building neural networks
they tend to be graph neural networks
but generally speaking neural networks
that are capable of executing
algorithmic computation so if I give you
some context on what is the state of a
particular algorithm can my network
somehow learn to execute that algorithm
ideally in some latent space such that
at every single step of the way I could
if I wanted to decode the states of that
algorithm so that's basically the the
main premise why do we care about this
well basically I think of algorithms as
a sort of basic foundational building
block of reasoning and it's kind of a
Timeless principle where you know a
software engineer reads through one of
these textbooks and algorithms and you
know learns these 30 or 40 basis
algorithms and then that knowledge kind
of serves them for life in a whole
career of software engineering so
basically we have this hypothesis that
you have this you know nice basis of
algorithms that if you can Master how to
do them robustly you can kind of try to
mimic any kind of at least polynomial
time reasoning behavior and that's
really nice because if you look at the
way current state-of-the-art large-scale
models tend to have shortcomings it's
usually in those kinds of robust
extrapolation problems basically if we
want to give if we want to have a really
good AI scientist that's able to not
just you know make a great sense of a
bunch of training data from the internet
but also use that training data to
derive new knowledge you need some
robustified way to apply rules to get
you know infinite Knowledge from finite
means right so basically that's what we
want to do we want to find ways
inductive biases or training procedures
to build neural networks that are more
algorithmically capable and in
algorithmic reasoning we obviously spent
a lot of time trying to make this happen
just building better graph neural
networks that align better with Target
algorithms so that you can execute them
better neurally but then the really
exciting part comes where we've actually
taken some of these graph neural
networks that have been pre-trained to
execute one particular algorithm and
then we deployed it in a real world
problem where that algorithm is required
and we achieved say significant
representational benefits in terms of
Downstream accuracy so the idea behind
this and I'll give an example from
Google Maps this is an application that
I worked on at deepmind so it's like
something that I've thought about quite
a bit
you know we've invented these algorithms
like dijkstra's algorithm to be able to
resolve these kinds of real-world
routing problems right that's the kind
of motivation for why you want to build
a shortest path algorithm and you know
it comes as a little surprise that when
you have real world traffic data you
might be tempted to apply the extras
algorithm to solve it to Route agents
and traffic however uh what is the
actual data let's say Google Maps has
access to it's not you know this nice
abstractified graph with a single scalar
in every Edge where you can just go
ahead and apply an algorithm in fact
there's a huge bridge that must be built
between the real data and the input to
the algorithm in fact Google Maps data
is typically you know people's cell
phones in their cars and the cars move
the phones move and then based on the
movement of the phones you somehow infer
how fast the car is going or something
like that right and you know this is
very noisy not very well structured and
you have to somehow go from there to a
graph where you can apply this heuristic
previously it was always done
exclusively by humans like feature
engineers effectively and whenever
there's a human feature engineer in the
loop like this you're almost certainly
going to drop a lot of information that
you might need to solve the problem so
basically we have a huge kind of Bridge
to cross there and with algorithmic
reasoning we now don't use dijkstra's
algorithm we use a high dimensional
graph net that was pre-trained to
execute dijkstra's algorithm in a latent
space so now this gives us a
differentiable component that we can
hook up to any encoder and decoder
function we want to so we can go
straight from raw data and code it into
the gnn's latent space run the algorithm
there and then decode whatever it is
that you need like routing the the
vehicles in traffic so now purely
through back prop this encoder function
now learns to do what the human feature
engineer did it learns how to most
effectively map that complicated noisy
real world data into the latent space
where this GNN can best do its thing
that really is software 2.0 but I wanted
to ask you about the computational
limitations because you just said
something interesting about you know
representing um you know infinite
objects with the finite memory so neural
networks are not touring machines yes
um but but they can extrapolate of
course yeah what what's the realistic
limitation let's say you're trying to
learn an algorithm
um how far can you go with a neural
network
so the thing is there are cases where
you can go very far we do have theory
that is very robust about this and I
think it's theory that is actually quite
easily understandable uh so let me try
to let me try to kind of uh visualize it
imagine you have a relief MLP your
standard Universal approximator it's
basically a piecewise linear function
right so as you go far enough away from
the training data you're going to hit
that level of extrapolation where you
hit the linear parts of the piecewise
linear and at that point if your target
function is not linear no extrapolation
is going to happen right you're not
going to fit the function properly so
what's one outcome of this theory is
that if you use relu MLPs this was a
great paper from MIT a few years back
which showed that basically
um you need to line up parts of your
neural network such that they learn
linear functions in the Target and
that's the reason why I say when you
want to imitate a pathfinding algorithm
you want to use a Max segregation your
GNN and not some where you know sum is
universal it can fit anything but the
function you have to learn because
pathfinding is like minimum overall
neighbors of distance to neighbor plus
the edge weight suddenly you know when
you put Max in there it's a linear
function when you put some in there it's
a highly non-linear function so it's
going to extrapolate much worse now
there's been some great follow-up work
on this from Beatrice Bruno Rivero from
Purdue University that was at icml a few
years back which showed that this idea
would like you want linear targets with
rarely MLPs it's really just a special
case of a more general idea that if you
want to extrapolate say on different
sizes of graphs you need you to have
some implicit causal model of what your
test data is going to look like this
linear algorithmic alignment is just one
special case of a causal model like that
so those are so basically if you line
things up properly from a causal
perspective you should in principle be
able to extrapolate I mean we have a
clear non-parametric evidence that you
can extrapolate is the algorithm itself
right now the key is to find the right
sweet spot between full Universal
proximator MLPs and algorithms on the
other side right interesting I spoke to
Yan the other day he had um he had a
paper a couple of years ago about you
know extrapolation and neural networks
saying that you always extrapolate yes
and I've been speaking with Rando
balestriero and he's got this paper the
spline theory of neural networks which
is about you know yeah these input
sensitive um polyhedra in the ambient
space and I I always took that to
Meanwhile they're quite interpolative
and it's just an affine transformation
for a single input but what he's shown
though is that actually even an MLP with
relu's is extremely extrapolative
because um you can remove a whole bunch
of data and um depending on how you've
designed the network architecture it
will still inform that region that that
you've taken away so I mean I don't know
are you familiar with the spline Theory
and do you think it's a useful framework
yeah so one thing I would say the way I
understand Jan's paper it could be that
that I missed some detail but the way I
understand it is that here we're talking
about interpolation extrapolation with
respect to the geometry of the data so
like you take say the convex Hull of all
the training points and then yeah it's
very common especially in these high
dimensional image spaces right it's very
easy to push one dimension sufficiently
to escape the convex Hull of what you've
seen so far so I guess when I say
extrapolation out of distribution I'm
actually maybe thinking of a more
probabilistic argument so something like
if you think of the probability
distribution induced by the training set
which obviously allows you to
extrapolate away from the convex call
right but if you go sufficiently far
from the modes of that distribution so
you explore a part of the space that
hasn't really been covered uh you know
from a from probabilistic Mass point of
view in the training data that is where
that is what we're actually thinking of
when we say out of distribution
generalization but yeah I fully agree
with you like in terms of just convex
Hall arguments we very often ask the
Israeli MLPs to go beyond the comics all
and they seem to work quite well in
those regimes but here I'm talking
really about going like significantly
beyond the convex Alto like some region
that really wasn't touched and what we
do for example in our papers is we train
on 16 the node graphs to execute these
algorithms and then we test it on four
times larger 64 node graphs and what
this means because an algorithm might
have say n the Cube's time complexity it
means the trajectory over which you have
to roll it out is also much much longer
than what you've seen in training time
so it's really a test of like very
different conditions than what you've
seen at training time right I understand
yeah and then first of all I completely
agree with you that this binary convex
our notion of of extrapolation probably
isn't isn't particularly useful
um but um you know um folks like
Francois relay um describe the way
neural networks work is kind of bending
the space um you know progressively with
wooden players but I really like this um
polyhedra idea
um contrast the algorithmic reasoning
with GNN semi nice work we've had a year
so from Google Brenton the other day
she's doing the um the the in context
prompting um you know for algorithm
learning and what energy contrast those
two approaches Yeah so basically I would
really like these approaches to be
reconciled going forward in the sense
that uh like I don't see them as going
one without the other if that makes
sense so on one side and I'm gonna
invoke the same principles I mentioned
during our during our mlst episode you
know Daniel conman's book system one and
system two right I think you cannot have
one without the other so you have these
amazing large-scale perceptive models
that are really amazing at you know
taking the complexities of the real
world and somehow getting interpretable
enough Concepts out of there that they
can you know make sense of what's going
on and like Drive many interesting real
world decision-making problems although
they might lose a little bit on having
to do something like what an AI
scientist would be expected to do which
is like extrapolate and generate New
Concepts out of what they've seen and as
you said these kinds of specifically
tailored prompts might enable the model
to take things a step or two further but
it's always like it's kind of in in
spirit it's the same thing as
algorithmic reasoning because we teach a
model to execute an algorithm by forcing
it to imitate the algorithm step by step
here you prompt a language model by
telling it what are some of the steps
like just like you're trying to teach a
student how to solve a homework right
telling them the individual steps they
need to do and then letting the language
model go off on its own to solve it but
where I see the real future of these two
two methods converging is you're going
to have your system one component that
gets your Concepts out very nicely
cleanly and then those Concepts because
we're working with Transformers nowadays
anyway most of the time are going to be
very slot based so that plays very
nicely with gnns which expect nodes as
input right so you can maybe hook up in
some nice way those Concepts into a
graph neural network that was trained to
execute a bunch of algorithms and then
you know kind of get the best of both
worlds so have your perceptual component
do the perception and maybe prompted as
well to kind of do it in a particularly
step-by-step Manner and then further
have a robust component that makes you
not have to relearn all those things
that neural networks we know
theoretically cannot learn to do that
well because of these extrapolation
arguments maybe one last point that will
make the kind of cement this if you've
been around the archive recently you
might have seen our paper on a
generalist neural algorithmic learner
where we have actually used gato style
ideas to train one graph neural network
that can execute 30 very diverse
algorithms all in the same architecture
with a single set of Weights so sorting
searching pathfinding dynamic
programming Comics Halls all those kinds
of nice things very diverse ways of
reasoning We Believe something like that
could maybe be a basis of say a
foundation model of reasoning in the
future that could nicely hook up to the
foundation models we already know and
love in the realm of perception amazing
and what's the biggest research
challenge for you next year so next year
I would really like to show to what
extent these things can scale in the
real world so we already have several
isolated papers that showed that these
ideas can work on real problems we have
excellent where we applied it to the
reinforcement learning that was in
Europe Spotlight last year we have RMR
where we applied it to self-supervision
problems we also have one paper
currently on the review at iClear where
we successfully applied to supervised
learning so we say pre-train on a flow
algorithm and we deploy it on like brain
vessel segmentation tasks and stuff like
that so we have many isolated cases
where you learn a particular algorithm
and it works really well in a real world
scenario like I would like to see how
can we take this idea and truly put it
to the test at larger scales both in
terms of number of problems we attack or
number of nodes that we support or
anything in between amazing Dr
patavalichkovic let's just um we'll get
we'll get a shaking handshots
thank you so much for joining us thank
you for having me I really appreciate it
Dr ishan mizra of meta and Lex Friedman
Fame came over and had a chat with us
ishan is one of the world's leading
experts in computer vision
so what was your paper about uh yeah
basically we tried to have like Global
propagation the likes of what you see in
Transformers but like uh you know with
sparse uh sparse costs right so but in a
way that like will still allow you to
have nice Global Communication
properties and no bottlenecks and stuff
like that so we basically have this idea
of you could generate like these
expander graphs which allow you to have
nice sparsity properties so basically
every node I think has degree four in
the graphs we we compute and you need
only logarithmically many steps to
Traverse the graph which means you can
still do it efficiently with a small
number of steps
um and yeah it seems to empirically work
well in a bunch of graph benchmarks so
yeah it's uh I think it's only
scratching the surface of what we can do
because we literally just generate a
graph at random and slap it onto like
mask the computations but uh yeah it's
an interesting start very nice yeah how
about your conference how's it been so
it's been pretty good uh we're
organizing the self-supervised learning
Workshop which is going to be probably I
hope like you useful to a lot of people
you're going to have a bunch of speakers
coming from Vision language NLP like
speech and so on right and yeah we're
also presenting a poster there which is
about learning joint image and video
representations which are state of the
art across image and video benchmarks
using a single model nice on the final
day of the conference I caught up with
Petra again at the poster session for
new reps which is the Symmetry and
geometry and neural representations
group and his paper was selected by all
of the reviewers at the conference as
being in the top 10 which is super
impressive but this is PETA talking
about his paper so uh in the expended
graph propagation work we are trying to
solve what is in my opinion one of the
most important problems in graph
representation learning currently
unsolved which is the over squashing
problem and effectively it is a task
which it's a problem which plagues graph
neural networks regardless of which
parameters you choose or which model you
choose it's really something that often
depends on the topology of the graph and
it's a situation where no matter how
hard you try no matter which parameters
you set
the amount of features you would need to
compute so the size of your latent space
would have to be exponential in the
number of layers for the pairs of nodes
to efficiently communicate we don't
always know when it happens but very
often it tends to happen around these
bottlenecks so basically in this
particular graph you have these two
communities that are tightly connected
and you have this just one critical Edge
connecting them and this Edge is now
under a lot of pressure if you want data
from these nodes to travel to these
nodes and vice versa this no this Edge
has to be mindful of a lot of things so
the size of the of the feature space
required for this Edge grows
exponentially and things get even worse
when you look at trees trees are like
the canonical worst case examples where
you know cutting off this Edge would
really trigger all sorts of bottleneck
cases and essentially you need basically
a number of the store information about
a number of nodes that grows
exponentially in the in the number of
steps just to be able to travel to the
other side of the tree so this is a
fundamental problem of propagating data
which has nothing to do with the choice
of model just you know topology
and what do we try to do to fix this
problem you would ideally want so first
we start off with the assumption that
this kind of global talking is actually
beneficial of course there are some
tasks where you might not want data to
travel in this way because if it's a
highly homophilous data-driven problem
then you might want information to stay
in the community to not get diluted but
we assume in many tasks like say
molecular property prediction tasks you
actually want data to travel globally so
that's exactly what we do uh that's our
first assumption as we just described we
don't really want these bottlenecks to
exist because if there's a bottleneck no
matter what you do with the model it's
not going to work well we would ideally
want the complexity to be scalable so we
can apply this to graphs of arbitrary
sizes you know one simple solution to
this problem is to use like a graph
Transformer which would connect every
node to every other node and give you
kind of a trivially setting with no
bottlenecks however and as we will show
later Transformer you know these fully
connected graphs are trivial dense
expanders actually so they fit our
Theory but they are dense and they won't
scale so we don't necessarily want that
and lastly because it's often quite
computationally painful to kind of clear
these bottlenecks in a kind of input
data-driven way especially if you have
lots of online graphs coming into your
problem we might ideally want a method
that doesn't have to do like dedicated
pre-processing of the input graph and
actually satisfying all four of these at
the same time turns out to be quite
tricky we actually have you know done a
literature survey of bunch of related
works and it seems really hard to tick
all four of these boxes and our method
the expanded graph propagation tends to
take all four of them so how do we do it
basically we propose to propagate
information over these expander graphs
which are known constructs from graph
Theory specifically expanded graphs have
mathematical properties of a high
trigger constant so very low bottlenecks
which is good a low diameter meaning
you'll get Global Information
propagation very efficiently however
additionally we can build expanders in a
sparse manner using this standard
mathematical construction from the
special linear group and that actually
guarantees us that the degree of every
node will be four and therefore the
graph will be sparse and actually the
only generative parameter of these
graphs is the size of the group this n
over here so it's very easy to generate
an expander for a particular number of
nodes you just tell me what any you want
and I'll give you a graph that this is
in time so when you look at an expander
it looks something like this it is
basically what I like to say it looks a
bit like the human human brain right
every node kind of has this very local
connectivity to its four immediate
neighbors but as you go far away like
login steps you get a lot of Cycles
being closed very quickly and the Global
Communication properties get like really
good so that's our proposal take
basically you know your state-of-the-art
graph net that you care about we
literally just take the code actively
available implementation we switch the
graph neural network
connectivity in every even layer to
operate over one of these guys rather
than the input graph so basically you
kind of alternate input graph expander
graph input graph expander graph so that
the input graphs layers are responsible
for the usual local computations that a
GNN wants to do and the expander layers
are responsible within diffusing that
information globally in a sparse and
scalable way and this seems to work well
so in all the data sets we tried this
construction it was better than the
Baseline and as I said all we did was
change the connectivity so the number of
parameters is exactly the same it's
really like apples to apples comparison
and it led to like statistically
significant significant results one last
point I would like to make is you know
we're not the only group that tried to
study this problem concurrently to us
the group of Michael bronstein with Jake
topping and Francesco de Giovanni had
this great paper on curvature analysis
which was actually one of the best paper
awardees that iClear 2022. and basically
in this paper they claim that if you
have negatively curved edges so edges
with a very negative curvature those
tend to be the ones responsible for the
formation of bottlenecks and therefore
over squashing and so naturally we
wanted to connect our expanders to this
Theory so we computed the curvature of
our graphs but we found that actually
the graphs that we build are negatively
curved everywhere so it has a curvature
of negative one very quickly as you
increase the size of the graph right so
obviously you know we built a negatively
curved graph everywhere yet it still
seems to work well so what gives right
we try to analyze this a bit further
first we showed that the curvature of
negative one is actually not that small
like the theory from in this paper is
only invoked when the curvature is close
to -2 so in our case with curvature of
negative one it's actually not
sufficiently negative to trigger that
failure case of this theorem and
additionally we took it a step further
and we actually tried to analyze how
easy it is to satisfy these three
properties at once so to have sparsity
we said sparsity is good for scalability
to have a low bottlenecks so a high
trigger constant which would mean you
don't have these kinds of pathological
propagation problems and thirdly to have
positive curvature which seems to be a
good idea based on the analysis of this
paper and we actually proved there is a
theorem in our paper that proves that
these three things are incompatible with
each other in that there's only finitely
many graphs that satisfy these three
properties simultaneously so as you go
to large enough input graphs to be
sparse and to have no bottlenecks you
have to be negatively curved somewhere
it's impossible to avoid it so while we
don't study the implications of this any
further we do believe that it calls on
the community community in the future to
study what happens in this gray area
where the curvature is negative but not
too negative because it seems like
something like that might be critical to
having the most optimal message passing
possible and that is basically the rough
summary of our work yeah